hello english please  i'm surrounded by idiots  i am completely different from my family  why is she avoiding us they're both  growing up so fast pretty hot hey ladies  i have the very solution we are going on  a family vacation  let's roll  [Music]  you've always wanted to see more of this  great country  right in the niagara falls  hi what's your talent  there's my little holy terror  i remember the night wednesday was born  it was a tuesday she was silent that's a  jellyfish and i put all the babies back  where i found them huh i think  [Music]  we need to stop that family so the truth  can come out  who is that man no one at all do you  this trip will bring the atoms closer  than ever before  or there will be no survivors  it's just us and the wonderful sound of  silence  [Music]  [Music]  it's  good to see you my big whisker cousin  i still don't understand the word that  guy says  [Music]  you